alors c'est lucie pas qui je te manque
déjà est ce que je te manque la lumière
et le spectacle semble lui avoir manqué
pour son grand retour publiques donald
trump a fait du donald trump offensif
est toujours aussi provocateur
l'ancien président des états unis est
revenu sur son mandat je me tiens devant
vous aujourd'hui pour déclarer que
l'incroyable voyage que nous avons
commencé ensemble nous avons vécu un
voyage comme personne d'autre
il n'y a jamais eu de voyage comme celui
ci il n'y a jamais eu de voyage aussi
réussi nous l'avons commencé ensemble il
y a quatre ans et il est loin d'être
terminée donald trump qui refuse
toujours d'admettre son revers à
l'élection présidentielle semble tourner
vers l'avenir
devant une foule acquise à sa cause il
s'est montré très confiant quant à la
suite des événements pour lui il n'ya
pas de doute les républicains vont
récupérer le pouvoir avec votre aide
nous reprendrons la chambre des
représentants nous reprendrons le sénat
et ensuite un président républicain fera
un retour triomphant à la maison blanche
qui qui qui se rase je me demande qui
sait je pourrai décider de les battre
une troisième fois
même si elle n'est pas explicite cette
déclaration a tout d'un appel du pied de
donald trump à propos de la course à la
présidentielle 2024 depuis sa défaite
face à joe biden de nombreuses rumeurs
sur son retour ce pécule aux etats-unis
avec notamment la possibilité de créer
son propre parti politique
une option balayé par l'homme d'affaires
de 74 ans
[Applaudissements]
ne créons pas de nouveaux partis vous
savez il n'arrêtait pas de dire il va
créer un tout nouveau parti nous avons
le parti républicain il va s'unir et
être plus fort que jamais je ne vais pas
créer un nouveau parti
malgré les derniers sondages d'opinion
plutôt favorable à l'administration
byden donald trump s'est attaqué à la
nouvelle équipe en place à la maison
blanche
[Musique]
joe biden a connu le premier mois le
plus désastreux de tous les présidents
de l'histoire moderne
c'est vrai l'administration by dunn a
déjà prouvé qu'elle était anti emploi
anti famille anti frontières anti
énergie anti femmes et anti science
malgré une image sulfureuse un parti
républicain divisé à son égard et une
accusation d'incitation à l'insurrection
dans la taille du capitole le 6 janvier
dernier
donald trump garde la cote auprès des
conservateurs selon un sondage publié la
semaine dernière par le site
d'information américain politico 53% des
républicains sont prêts à voter de
nouveau pour donald trump aux primaires
du parti
loin devant les autres potentiels
candidats mieux encore selon un autre
sondage du morning consulte 81% des
républicains garde une opinion positive
de l'ancien président des états unis